In this case there's not really a right answer because there's
many, many features that you could identify in a piece of
software as complex as a, a spreadsheet. So I'm just going
to give you three examples. So one could be the cell merging
operation. So the operation in which we merge two cells in
the spreadsheet. Another example could be chart creation, so I might want
to test the feature that allows you to create charts in
your spreadsheets. Yet another example could
be the test of statistical functions,
so the function that allows you to do various statistical calculations on
the numbers in your cells. And as I said there's many, many
more example that we could use. But the key thing I want
to convey here is the fact that there is no way you
can look at a spreadsheet with all the functionality that it provides
and just go and test it. The first step, what you need
to do first, is to identify which ones are the pieces of
functionality that I can test individually. So that's why this is the
first step in black-box testing.